bonjour à tous bienvenue dans votre
édition du 12 13 ans en normandie nous
revoici au sein des jeux équestres
mondiaux en direct du village
florent turpin bonjour vous êtes notre
journal de ce sportif les compétitions
se poursuivent ce minimum oui bonjour 27
deuxième journée de compétition a
commencé à 8 heures ce matin regarder ça
continue en ce moment même c'est en
direct au stade michel d'ornano où le
dressage se poursuit bonne nouvelle il a
fait plutôt beau ce matin sur tous les
sites de compétition ça va peut-être pas
durer en tout cas pas de pluie mais
plein de belles images
on verra ça tout à l'heure et roanne on
vous retrouve dans un instant reparle
des jeux juste après un petit détour par
l'actualité de ce midi en normandie avec
d'abord le remaniement ministériel après
la démission du gouvernement valls 1
hier la composition du gouvernement
valls 2 est attendu dans la journée
on surveillera attentivement le devenir
des deux ministres normand laurent
fabius ministre des affaires étrangères
sortant devrait être reconduit dans la
nouvelle mouture tout comme l'ancien
député maire de cherbourg bernard
cazeneuve le ministre de l'intérieur
sortant l'homme annulé une visite prévue
aujourd'hui dans le cotentin côté
entrant pressenti on évoque l'écologiste
d'origine caennaise jean vincent placé
on saura tout ça dans la journée dans
l'actualité également ce midi un grand
soulagement pour tous les automobilistes
rouennais avec l'inauguration du pont
mathilde fermé après un incendie en
octobre 2012 il ouvrira à 17 heures cet
après midi marie du mesnil adelée
bonjour vous êtes déjà sur place tout à
fait c'est simple geste ces quelques pas
sont un événement croyez-moi emprunter
le pont mathilde à pied comme chien le
fer à cheval puisque cette saison chez
vous dans votre région mais surtout
surtout en voiture ou en camion nombreux
sont ceux à l'avoir rêver pendant les 22
mois de fermeture dans une ville de
rouen ont totalement saturée imaginé
avant d'être fermée ce pont accueillez
80 mille véhicules par jour 80 mille
véhicules forcément redirigés ailleurs
sur les autres ponts de la ville sur les
quais provoquant des embouteillages
quotidiens alors oui cette réouverture à
la circulation c'est un gros ouf de sous
engagement pour tous les automobilistes
passant par la ville de rouen mais
attention pour l'instant il n'est ouvert
qu'aux piétons jusqu'à 15 heures la
réouverture à la circulation se fera à
17 heures avant sa place à la parade
avec une fanfare l'inauguration
officielle une exposition de voitures de
collection
bref c'est un petit peu le moment où les
élus s'autocongratule bon il faut avouer
que c'est un exploit pour un chantier de
cette ampleur à près de 8 millions
d'euros d'avoir respecté le calendrier
annoncé juste après l'accident trois
mois après une réouverture pile pour la
rentrée des classes était promise c'est
désormais chose faite
nous y reviendrons largement ce soir en
haute normandie avec une page spéciale
merci marie à quand la désillusion des
21 salariés de l'hôtel malherbe
ils ont appris hier la fermeture
définitive de leur établissement céder à
un promoteur immobilier
la fin de l'activité est prévue d'ici à
la fin de l'année thiery cléon sylvain
rouil d'ici la fin du mois d'octobre
voire descendre 2014 l'ancien hôtel
malherbe fermera donc définitivement ses
portes une décision économique selon la
direction l'hôtel n'était plus rentable
une décision tous les cas dramatiques
qui impacte 21 salariés en cdi
sans oublier les extras et les emplois
indirects il ya une désillusion est
immense dans la tête des salariés et
c'est une journée noire clairement oui
c'est compliqué à vivre un propriétaire
depuis 1990 le groupe lauréat a donc
décidé de vendre l'immeuble à france
pierre patrimoine un promoteur
immobilier bordelais le célèbre bâtiment
où ont séjourné dali ou bien encore le
général eisenhower va être transformé en
appartements de standing
selon le syndicat le feu vert pour
lancer ce projet a été donné par la
mairie de caen et les bâtiments de
france
c'est d'autant plus étonnant que notre
meilleur actuelle avait basé sa campagne
municipale sur l'emploi on ne peut pas
dire que on est vous on y vit beaucoup
monsieur bruno s'investir sur le dossier
jeannette est la pire en corse et qui
donne son accord pour faire en sorte que
cet hôtel de vienne
une entreprise immobilière alors qu'il
avait les moyens d'empêcher cette vente
une réunion pour évoquer les mesures de
reclassement et d'accompagnement du
personnel de l'hôtel se déroulera
mercredi prochain la direccte à
hérouville saint clair
on dirait que toujours des jeux
équestres mondiaux dans ce studio monté
au sein du village nous revenons à
présent à l'évènement mondial de cheval
avec d'abord la compétition avec vous
florent on en parlait longuement hier le
reining se poursuit ce matin et samedi
le reining ça se passe au parc des
expositions juste à côté ça continue en
ce moment en regard des ambiances rodéo
et western et toujours des figures assez
impressionnante
ce premier tour de qualification se
termine ce soir et en attendant le
passage du français franck perrais
numéro 1 mondial cet après midi c'est
l'américain fera pas ni l'autre grande
star de la discipline qui est en tête du
classement alors qu'un petit et bas
normands que vous voyez sur ces images
est passé ce matin il s'appelle bastia
bourgeois originaire de dieppe il habite
à bellengreville dans le calvados et il
a pris la 27e place du classement
écoutez le c'était il ya quelques
minutes au micro de franck besnier ici
voilà on a en france
les trois quarts des gradins sont
remplies par des français effectivement
ils attendent donc voilà comme j'ai dit
je suis un peu déçu du score où ça va
pas forcément
et est ce que j'attendais j'attendais un
petit peu plus voilà les jugeons pas
crédité ces voix là c'est bon tu disais
c'est du haut niveau et là c'est dur
d'aller chercher des points du para
dressage également ce matin avec un
autre passage français oui ça se passe
cette fois à l'hippodrome de caen et
sous le soleil mais devant et des
tribunes encore bien vide il faut le
dire en par adressage les cavaliers sont
handicapés vous le savez qui sont
répartis en grade selon l'importance de
leur handicap
ce matin place aux cavaliers de grade 4
vous voyez ici sur ces images la
française nathalie bizet qui après un
super passage est pour l'instant 5e du
classement provisoire 3e disciplinaire a
continué le dressage
ouais direction maintenant le stade
michel d'ornano deuxième journée de
qualifications pour le grand prix
spécial de dressage la piste détrempée
hier a eu le temps de sécher
heureusement et comme prévu
ce sont toujours les cavaliers allemands
qui sont en tête du classement au profit
ouah ce matin vous la voyez la française
jessica michel a fait son entrée dans la
compétition
la cavalière de l'équipe de france est
pour l'instant 39e après un passage
moyen on va dire merci florent est
justement ce midi on s'arrête un instant
sur cette discipline du dressage une
épreuve très codifié parfois difficile à
comprendre mais rassurez vous
rassurez-vous vous saurez tout ou
presque avec cet éclairage signée
corinne derosa ils sont les grands
favoris de l'épreuve de dressage
l'anglais ce charme du jardin et son
cheval va les gros après le forfait de
dernière minute du célèbre étalon noir
totilas le dressage une discipline qui a
considérablement évolué ces dernières
années
d'entendre ça ce n'était qu'une
succession d'exercice et aujourd'hui on
a cette succession d'exercice mais ça
doit être fait d'une certaine manière
avec donc un la première qualité un
cheval qui se déplacent de façon très
élégante avec aussi de la souplesse de
la puissance
c'est ça qu'on recherche aujourd'hui en
dressage les couples exécute une série
de figures dans des programmes libres ou
imposer est noté comme au patinage
artistique
la pirouette consiste à faire tourner le
cheval autour de ces postérieur
l'appuyer est un exercice dans lequel le
cheval se déplace latéralement en
croisant ses membres
le passage est un trop majestueux d'une
grande lenteur à caen l'équipe de france
ne part pas favorite mais espère quand
même aller le plus loin possible et je
n'ai qu'à ce mendiant c'est
effectivement c'est effectivement un
rêve c'est quelque chose auquel on se
prépare réellement il faut savoir qu'on
n'y pense pas juste 10 jours avant toute
la saison et même la saison d'avant
encore on y pense c'est en france donc
c'est c'est un endroit spécial pour nous
on a on va voir le public qui qui est
avec nous on a à coeur de montrer ce que
l'on sait faire et ce que l'on peut
faire et puis de montrer que le dressage
en france on commence vraiment existé
esthétisme émotions communion le
dressage est la seule discipline
équestre que l'on qualifie d' artistique
on continue à parler d'indiscipliné on
va rejoindre le stade d'ornano se trouve
en ce moment me corinne bien rose avec
les épreuves de dressage qui se
poursuivent
corinne vous êtes en compagnie de la
directrice technique nationale adjointe
de l'équipe de france oui tout à fait il
ya de l'ambiance ici aussi au dressage
vous rassure il n'y a pas qu'eux
auraient ning effectivement je suis donc
avec emmanuel schramm emmanuel on a vu
passer donc jessica michel ce matin un
score autour de 67 une petite déception
pour vous un petit peu oui parce que
c'est elle est un peu en dessous de les
performances qu'elle faisait d'habitude
cette année
mais quand même
elle était quand même présente elle a
donné elle a fait de son meilleur et
puis la partie pas fini on est dans
l'épreuve par équipe et cet après midi
on a notre quatrième équipier français
arnaud serre et c'est robinson qui vont
défendre de couleurs encore donc rien
n'est perdu
alors c'est la première fois qu'on a une
véritable équipe à londres jusqu'à
michel était tout seul
là il ya une véritable équipe et on sent
vraiment que la discipline du dressage
est en train de se structurer en france
oui c'est vrai on n'avait pas d'équipé
personnes à lexington derniers jeux
mondiaux l'année elle il ya deux ans à
londres jessica était seul et c'était un
des objectifs majeurs pour la fédération
de reconstituer une équipe de
reconstituer une dynamique et c'est
chose faite il ya une excellente
ambiance
terminez tous les espoirs un peu son sur
marc boblet sur marc lui a priori ils
seraient qualifiés pour le grand prix
spécial déjà puisqu'il est passé hier et
avec une très bonne performance est
maintenant sur arnaud serre alors on
croise des doigts emmanuel merci merci à
vous corinne on va partir à présent
haras du pin dans l'orne où débuteront
en fin de semaine elle est première
épreuve du concours complet cavaliers et
chevaux sont déjà sur place
des montures qui sont véritablement
traité comme des athlètes de haut niveau
une armée de vétérinaires sud de très
près leur état de santé
reportage sur place tu d'adèle de
celle-ci et de patrick mertz irritation
sur la peau à quelques jours du concours
complet la moindre blessure est prise
très au sérieux par le vétérinaire de
l'équipe
une infection locale j'ai un petit peu
leur médecin de famille je les connais
très bien je les ai suivis tout au long
de la saison je les ai vus en
compétition j'ai participé au stage de
préparation à la sélection en tout 35
vétérinaires seront sur le site au
moment des épreuves une clinique a été
installé pour gérer les chevaux malades
ou blessés on a cinq boxes qu'on appelle
des votes traitements qui permettent aux
vétérinaires des clips de traiter leurs
chevaux on a toute une série de bureaux
pour les vétérinaires on à la pharmacie
on peut tous traités on va dire les
premières urgences
et puis dès que ça va devenir un petit
peu compliqué nécessitant beaucoup de
médicaments ou en tout cas des moyens
peut-être un peu plus important que ce
qu'on a ici c'est évacuer référés vers
des cliniques à l'extérieur pour que
rien ne vienne perturber les jeux
équestres les vétérinaires suivent la
santé des chevaux de très près dès leur
arrivée un premier examen est réalisée
pour évaluer l'état général de l'animal
fréquence cardiaque vaccination
température endroit pour lever tout est
vérifié comme pour les athlètes de haut
niveau
les diagnostics doivent pouvoir être
fait au plus vite sur le site un
laboratoire est opérationnel 24 heures
sur 24 on va frotter un peu la muqueuse
nasale dufresne récolter quelques
quelques cellules et les éventuels les
aventures des agents pathogènes qui
pourrait que le cheval pourraient avoir
l'objectif détecter les animaux malades
pour éviter toute contamination
au total 178 binaires sont mobilisés
pour ces jeux équestres sur les
différents sites retour en direct du
village des jeux sur notre plateau où
nous avons le grand plaisir de recevoir
aller axel kahn généticien et essayiste
et ambassadeurs des jeux de ces jeux
équestres mondiaux bonjour merci d'être
avec nous en quoi consistait votre
difficile tâche d'être ambassadeur des
jeux équestres mondiaux populariser les
jeux et leur importance et je les fais
de manière particulière pour ce qui me
concerne puisque j'avais comme tous les
ambassadeurs la mascotte des jeux je
vous le présente chez normand mais j'ai
parcouru à pied plus de 2000 kilomètres
et plus de quarante trois mille mètres
de montée
et puis la pointe du raz jusqu'à menton
avec normand et comme j'aimais mieux
voyager avec une demoiselle qu'avec un
homme je les rebaptiser princesse
mascotte donc on a pu voir princesse
mascotte dans toute la france sur les
monts partout et vous êtes revenu avec
princess mascotte sur ces jeux équestres
votre regard sur l'organisation de
l'événement que vous avez pu suivre
depuis dimanche je crois c'est une très
grosse très belle organisation
je suis un amoureux inconditionnel du
cheval des cavaliers des cavalières et
tous les sports qui vont avec
et donc je nage un peu dans l'allégresse
voilà c'est ici pline favorite
oui moi même chez un homme de cheval
chez du cheval depuis que j'ai 5 ans je
préfère le saut d'obstacles l'extérieur
il complet chasse et traditionnelle mais
je me réjouis beaucoup de voir du
reining ce après midi à l'heure où on
l'équitation parle beaucoup génétique
clonage quel est votre regard de
généticiens sur ces évolutions
il y a deux grandes techniques nouvelles
la première c'est l'utilisation de la
génomique
c'est à dire arriver à associer les
caractères habituels sur la base
desquels on croise les mâles et les
femelles pour avoir de très bons
produits à des marqueurs génétiques
j'adhére d'e books on a repéré sur l'adn
qui véhicule les gènes et chasser le
métier de sélectionneur traditionnel
avec simplement une aide c'est
révolutionnaire dans la méthode pas du
tout dans le concept
et puis le clonage c'est complètement
différent car le clonage est le
contraire de la sélection et de la
génétique s'est arrêté à un moment donné
arrêtez la sélection puisqu'on considère
qu un reproducteur ou bien performeur et
absolument idéal on le clown et on va
pas plus loin non l'un est révolu chiens
dans les méthodes pas dans le but
l'autre est révolutionnaire et dans les
méthodes et dans le but les dans le but
entendu merci à vous axel kahn d'avoir
été sur ce plateau lors de ce 12 13 ce
midi en direct du village des jeux on va
rejoindre maintenant justement les
allées de ce village où nous attend
hélène jacques hélène
bonjour vous me parler cuisine ce midi
bonjour erwan bonjour à tous et
bienvenue s'est échauffé nous sommes en
plein pour tous vous initier à l'espace
dormant avec mon chef rebelle
cyril berne alors cyril à la recette du
jour c'est donc un waf de boeuf à la
bière du kantigui et c'est pas par
hasard
non c'est pas par hasard c'est vrai
c'est un petit clin d'oeil à notre
voyage il ya quatre ans pour faire la
promotion de notre région je séquestre
mondiaux au kentucky exactement à
lexington et j'avais réalisé une recette
de walk de boeuf à la bière du kentucky
et puis aujourd'hui on est chez nous en
normandie donc évidemment les produits
normands et puis un petit clin d'oeil
avec les saveurs du monde eh bien
aujourd'hui c'est avec la bière du
kentucky
pendant ses cours de cuisine à c'est
gratuit ça s'adresse à tout le monde
tout le monde peut réaliser cette
recette
oui exactement l'idée ce sont des
recettes simples original rapide et puis
avec des produits et des ingrédients
très abordable alors par exemple là pour
faire 7 pour faire cette recette il faut
combien de temps voilà allez bon on
discute on papote mais aller en dix
minutes un quart d'heure on suit une
super grosse est alors ça va être toutes
les heures à partir de midi jusqu'à 18
heures tous les jours ici il ya de tout
comme recette exactement aujourd'hui on
est sur la filière viande
hier c'était produit la mer demain ce
sont les produits sucrés et en plus j'ai
envie de dire oui on a des élèves
moi je suis là un petit peu le chef
d'orchestre mais j'ai aussi l'honneur de
recevoir des chefs normands des chefs de
cuisine de restaurant un chef de
restauration scolaire qui va venir tout
à l'heure pour le faire a demandé un
dauphin exactement c'est merci voilà
manon reste parce qu'on va goûter un
merci à vous et hélène de nous avoir
ouvert l'appétit christian choupin
bonjour jour les jeux équestres mondiaux
se poursuivre cet après midi sur france
3 aux alentours de 15 heures avec vous
allez on va suivre de manière très
sportive la fin de ce premier tour de
dressage avec notamment isabelle worf
qui est qui est très forte qui est passé
tout à l'heure on va revenir sur sa
performance et qui on va préparer on va
aussi parler de la préparation des
chevaux de la santé des chevaux par
exemple isabelle worf s'est fait prendre
à deux reprises en 2009 et en 2013 avec
des produits interdits
alors comment l'on prépare ses chevaux
qu'elle produit gercke quelle
préparation on peut leur soumettre les
produits interdits ceux qui ne le sont
pas c'est pas facile pour les athlètes
que sont les chevaux
qu'on va parler un peu de tout ça et on
va sur bien sûr aussi le reining parce
que c'est très important des trois
français qui passe aujourd'hui avec
notamment romuald de poires franck
perrais et cédric et guerrero la famille
guerrero qui est très impliqué dans le
reining donc de belles images sublimes à
suivre dès 15h10 sur france 3 et c'est à
suivre
effectivement sur france 3 à suivre
également sur internet sur le site
internet bastille rennes en mondy point
france 3 points et faire vous pouvez ce
matin il retrouvait notamment le
portrait et le parcours de la cavalière
de parra dressage anne-frédérique royon
l entrée en lice y est voilà merci à
tous d'avoir participé à ce 12 13 2 les
jeux équestres mondiaux reviennent sur
france 3 basse-normandie dès ce soir
après après le l'émission spéciale de 15
heures mais dans le 19/20 avec emilie
flahaut pour les téléspectateurs aux
normands vous retrouverez frédéric
nicolas pour votre journal régional
dans un instant la météo puis votre
journal national on se retrouve ici même
dès demain midi très bonne journée à
tous
où
m